there are some members of the democratic
party again who I don't think are are
quite as as crazed as like the Bernie
Squad wing of the democratic party but
the younger generation is definitely
moving in the wrong direction on all of
that and on the right side of the aisle
you do have a a younger generation uh
that is you know kind of trumpy in
orientation but it I've always had
trouble sort of determining exactly what
that means in terms of policy it seems
more like an affect than a policy the
the love for Trump is largely based on
the way that he approaches the world not
necessarily based on his policy which is
why I think that for everybody running
against him they're attacking Trump on
policy like Ron was running against him
from the right he was saying okay he's
wrong on this he's wrong on this I'm
right on this and the entire base was
like and everybody was like okay but
doesn't the policy matter and the answer
is no the policy doesn't matter the the
the AFF effect actually matters so you
know if that's the case I do think that
as the parties get more and more Brash
in their rhetoric uh there will be the
rise of of an independent party if if
rfk's campaign were more well organized
RFK would win 15 to 20% in this election
ction
cycle let's talk about the other side of
the aisle for a second because it seems
to me like Biden is the last vestage of
anything sayane we're going to see on
the Democrat side for a long long time
like they brought him in to kind of hold
the door and make sure the crazies
didn't get in he still let the crazies
in but he's old so people don't fully
realize it like is do you think this is
the end of anything close to a Democrat
Party that we've had America for the
last 50 years like after this it is the
party of the wackadoodle progressives
officially so I I do have some hope that
there are some people inside the
Democratic party who have not completely
lost their minds um John fedman would be
a great example of this right there
there still damage six months ago is now
the Sint as Democrat it's incredible
it's it's totally wild I mean make a
movie about that by the way it's it's
amazing it's like Awakenings it's like
it's like I said that on show earlier
it's it's totally amazing I mean man has
been incredible he's been great On the
Border he's been great on the Middle
East he's been great on a wide variety
of issues um I do think I hope it ends
better than Awakenings you know in
Awakenings he ends up back in the coma
yeah yeah no yeah hopefully there's no
parallel the the uh the you know kind of
status of the democratic party I think
that the Democratic party if they lose
an election that if they lose to Trump
the the left is going to take over the
party for the foreseeable future because
the reaction is going to be that they
lost because Biden was too moderate and
and the media are going to F me exactly
that now would it matter would it matter
because it seems to me that he's just
pretending not to be a bananas one the
policies are what what policy could
possibly be worse yes I mean the so the
only thing that matters that the open
Embrace of the policy does in fact lead
you down the slippery slope to the next
crazy thing so you know there there is
something to the idea that if Biden ran
as a moderate and then governed as a
leftist that that is better than him
running as a leftist and then governing
as a further leftist if you're always if
you always end up to the left of where
you of where you Campaign which is
pretty frequent right I mean that that
that seems to be the case uh for
republicans and Democrats by the way is
that you tend to govern more to the left
than you actually campaign D very often
um but certainly for Democrats if if you
govern to the left of where you
campaigned uh then where you campaign if
you can use that as sort of a baseline
then it kind of matters I suppose if you
if you campaign as a moderate or if you
feel that's where the appeal is at least
you're trying to read the American
people as opposed to being sort of the
fomenting factor in in generating hardle
pushes and there are some members of the
democratic party again who I don't think
are are quite as as crazed as like the
Bernie Squad wing of the democratic
party but the younger generation is
definitely moving in the wrong direction
on all of that and on the right side of
the aisle you do have a a younger
generation uh that is you know kind of
trumpy in orientation but it I've always
had trouble sort of determining exactly
what that means in terms of policy it
seems more like an affect than a policy
the the love for Trump is largely based
on the way that he approaches the world
not necessarily based on his policy
which is why I think that for everybody
running against him they're attacking
Trump on power policy like Ron was
running against him from the right he
was saying okay he's wrong on this he's
wrong on this I'm right on this and the
entire base was
like and everybody was like okay doesn't
the policy matter and the answer is no
the policy doesn't matter the the the
AFF effect actually matters so you know
if that's the case I do think that as
the parties get more and more Brash in
their rhetoric uh there will be the rise
of of an independent party if if
rfk's campaign were more well organized
RFK would win 15 to 20% in this election
cycle what do you think about what do
you think about him taking over the
libertarian party cuz that's being
talked about now then he gets ballot
access and then it's like you actually
could affect the election I'm not saying
he'd be president but if he got 20% of
the vote depending on who where it was
coming from it's like he absolutely
could swing the election yeah I mean I I
I think that if he did that the first
move he would have to make is to
defenestrate everyone in the libertarian
party right number one he's not a
Libertarian uh but number two uh I think
that the the stigma the brand stigma of
the libertarian party which is naked
people dancing around on stage with
their convention is pretty strong and if
the rip on RFK is he's a little Kookie
uh then associating with the Kookie
party is probably not helpful he'd be
better off going no labels if they
actually have ballot access because then
he can claimed to be sort of the
moderate middle-of the road guy who's
still rational and reasonable and again
like I think there are a lot of people
both right and left who would take a
look at RFK right but the fact of the
matter is the Libertarians are on all
the ballots and that that that shiny
thing might just be enough to make him
do it I want to ask you about the Border
stuff because there's something
interesting going on here and I I I've
watched some of your videos and I saw
what you're saying on Twitter and I'm
completely in agreement and that you
know these 25 Republican Governors are
doing the right thing and Abbott's doing
the right thing and all that but does
this put more conservative leaning
people in a bizarre position that
Suddenly at least the Optics of it
appear that we are now the ones who will
not listen to the Supreme Court and
that's not how it's supposed to be um so
I don't think that that optic is going
to work I mean number one it's not
legally true obviously there's been no
actual there's been no actual thing
demanded of the State of Texas the case
that went before The Supreme Court was
about whether the federal government has
the capacity to dismantle razor wire it
did not in fact tell the state of Texas
not to erect the Razer wire in the first
place and so you the state of Texas
actually hasn't violated supreme court
order at all at this point and what
they're doing right now is going to end
up being challenged in the courts
presumably if they would deny access or
if they would attempt to enforce some
sort of deportation orders on their own
I'm not aware that Governor abbid by the
way has actually done that I'm not aware
that there's been actually any policy
whereby people are being arrested and
then quote unquote deported by the state
of Texas I don't think that that's
actually happened yet they're being
pretty careful about how they're
approaching from a legal point of view
uh you know again I I don't think that
this is going to come down to Civil War
type actual you know actual Civil War
people fighting each other on the border
sort of thing um I I think that the the
worst case scenario here and this is why
I've been encouraging civilians to stay
out of that area uh is when you see
protesters who are deciding they're
going to go and they're going to stand
on the border we need to draw attention
to all this believe me the attention is
already there the last thing we need is
somebody coming to blows with the border
patrol agents and then Joe Biden and the
administration using that as an excuse
to crack down on everybody on the right
and open the border at the same time
like we don't need any of that well what
Abbott is doing is pretty well
calibrated at this point well I mean is
that would you do anything else if you
were Abbot so if you were if you were
the governor of a border state at this
point what would you be doing I mean
unless Abbot is again willing to look at
legal options as far as what deportation
actually looks like I think that it's
going to be a problem but yeah again in
the end this is going to be a a federal
issue like what he's doing right now by
basically saying okay fine you want to
you want to let people in Texas they're
going to Chicago that's a pretty good
policy I mean if if you're the governor
of Texas that's the right policy that
that is okay we're not going to absorb
the cost of this you guys voted for this
are going to absorb the cost of this I'm
not sure there's ever been a more
effective political stunt maneuver than
the shipping of illegal immigrants to
Sanctuary cities it's it's truly like an
amazingly effective political maneuver
so since we started the show by talking
about we've been doing this together for
about 10 years and things have
precipitously seemingly gotten worse or
at least crazier I mean it seems to me
that the Border thing is going to be the
thing that leads everything to really
getting crazy and I'm I'm not into this
Civil War conversation either but I
really do see almost no way around the
states going their separate ways at this
point it just does not just for the
reason that you just laid out that
you're saying the competent thing for a
republican Governor to do is send them
to Blue States well that can only hold
for so long I mean what do you make of
that General concept you know you've
probably seen that map going around
Twitter where they've got Texas and
border and some of those Southeast
States almost all the way into Arizona
not Civil War attacking each other on
the streets but just kind of separating
almost sort of how the founders were
kind of into it a little bit well I mean
this this basic idea that you need to
actually go back to a form of
subsidiarity I think would be the great
hope I mean it's the reason why people
like you and people like me left
California and went to a state that we
like better I'm I'm very much in favor
of the big sword I think that if you
don't like living a California lifestyle
then you should leave California and you
should go to Florida and if you don't
like Florida you should go to California
I think all of that is quite good but
they're will have to be at some point a
recognition that the federal government
cannot simply cram down on the half of
the country that doesn't like what the
federal government is doing federal
policy that if we are actually going to
share a country that shares for example
a foreign policy a tax system you know
and any sort of federal you know any
sort of federal programs if we're going
to do that then the the hand of the
government is going to have to get
lighter not heavier and my great fear is
that as people that it's that it's
General Tarkin right that as as the
galaxies are slipping out of his grasp
then he's going to he's going to grip
Tighter and I think that that's what
that's what you're starting to see from
the federal government when the real
answer to that would be you know let
everybody breathe a little bit like let
Texas be Texas let California be
California uh and yes enforce your basic
duties if by the way any president who
actually runs on that platform is going
to win any president who actually runs
on the platform of you know we're not
here to make California be Texas and
we're not here to make New York be
Florida but vice versa also applies and
also I'm enforcing the border and also
America is going to retain its position
as the most powerful country on the
planet that simple statement probably
makes you the president if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop screaming check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell